wir haben besuch bekommen unser bild
politik chef jan schiffer ist bei uns ja
gestern war annalena baerbock hier bei
uns bei bild live wir wollen noch mal
mit dir gemeinsam auf diese kernaussagen
von ihr schauen und im ersten clip geht
es um die das vertrauen russland und
auch zu den chinesen würde noch mal ganz
kurz rein dann analysieren wir weiter
wir können diesem russischen präsidenten
kein millimeter vertrauen und vielleicht
weil die chinesen mit nochmal berlino
zwiesel können wir den chinesen
vertrauen auch da ist die welt halt
nicht noch rosarot und auch in der
vergangenheit nicht nur rosarot gewesen
deswegen sie haben angesprochen ich
hätte ich ihn nicht aufgezählt china hat
nicht mit russland gestimmt sondern
china hat sich enthalten das ist
natürlich auch keine klare haltung aber
es hat deutlich gemacht dass china
zumindest bei dieser frage den
russischen präsidenten nicht voll und
ganz unterstützt es gibt natürlich von
unserer seite auch gespräche und zwar
intensiver mit china um deutlich zu
machen auch ihr müsst euch hier
positionieren weil das ist ein bruch der
internationalen ordnung ja annalena
baerbock spricht die sitzung der
un-vollversammlung an in der es um eine
resolution zur verurteilung des krieges
ging der hat china sich enthalten
ungefähr 150 länder haben für diese
resolution gestimmt also annalena
baerbock
mit einem klaren auftritt mit einem sehr
klaren auftritt gestern das war jetzt
nur ein kurzer ausschnitt das interview
bei bild live hat ja ungefähr eine halbe
stunde gedauert zusammen mit ihrer
kanadischen amtskollegen mélanie julie
war sie hier bei bild und das war ein
klartext interview wie wir es ja
eigentlich von ihr mittlerweile gewohnt
sind es war aber zum anderen auch ein
interview was doch eine gewisse ohnmacht
des westens putin gegenüber ausgedrückt
hat den annalena baerbock hat ja auch
das haben jetzt gerade noch nicht
gesehen auch gesagt dass derzeit putin
offenbar nicht zu stoppen ist aber
einmal konkret auf die aussage die sie
gerade jahr gemacht hat in bezug auf
putin und in bezug auf china das kann
man auch sehr deutlich als einen
seitenhieb vielleicht sogar als eine
abrechnung auf die vorgängerregierung
auf die regierung von angela merkel und
ihrem außenminister heiko maas beziehen
denn sie hat ganz klar gesagt die
beziehung die es gegeben hat zu china
auch in der vergangenheit die waren ja
auch nicht immer oder es war ja nicht
bei china immer alles rosarot und wir
wissen dass die bundeskanzlerin ja jedes
jahr nach china gefahren ist auch die
deutsche wirtschaft hat extrem von ihrem
china geschäft profitiert und
möglicherweise oder ziemlich sicher
haben deutsche firmen aber auch die
deutsche politik in den vergangenen
jahren viele dinge die in china passiert
sind einfach nicht richtig beachtet und
nicht darüber gesprochen und dann ging
es auch um gaslieferungen
sollte deutschland weiterhin gas aus
russland beziehen und da haben wir auch
noch mal in annalena baerbock aussage
rein
was tun sie ganz persönlich plant sie
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
haben sie die heizung abgedreht was
welche maßnahmen treffen sie auf dieser
privaten ebene
kritische fragen für den hier gut
persönliche fragen finde ich auch gut
aber heizung abdrehen ist ein guter
punkt aber auch dass wir diesen krieg
nicht stoppen deswegen finde ich muss
man jetzt hier wahnsinnig aufpassen dass
man nicht das gefühl vermittelt jeder
dreht jetzt mal die heizung ab oder
unterstützt flüchtlinge und dann ist
alles gut das ist ja das schlimme an
krieg es ist nicht einfach so alles gut
sondern wir müssen auf allen kanälen
alles versuchen auch in diesem punkt ja
sie ist wirklich als eine
realpolitikerin aufgetreten in allen
äußerungen die sie gemacht hat hat sie
gesagt was wünschenswert wäre aber was
eben auch nur machbar ist im moment ja
das ist ja interessant ist erinnert fast
ein bisschen an den start der rot-grünen
bundesregierung unter jos oder mit
joschka fischer gerhard schröder und
joschka fischer 1998 und leicht zu
beginn 99 gab es dann ja den
kosovo-einsatz wir erinnern uns an den
parteitag an dem joschka fischer dann
auch ein fahrplan vorgeworfen bekamen
die grüne basis hat geschaut dass es in
diesem jahr ein bisschen anders wir
sehen es ähnlich eine junge
bundesregierung mit grüner beteiligung
muss direkt mit einer kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung fielen sich dort
behaupten auch und annalena baerbock das
kann man sagen macht das eigentlich
schon mit großer bravour spricht eine
sehr klare sprache mein eindruck ist man
hört ihr fast stärker zu als dem
bundeskanzler sie ist in der tat auch
mit dem was sie fordert beispielsweise
beim thema nord stream zwei dem
bundeskanzler auch immer wenn nicht tage
aber zumindest stunden voraus also der
eindruck zumindest in der öffentlichkeit
ist annalena baerbock ist ein gewisser
weise takt schreiberin wir sehen aber
auch und das ist ganz klar die
bundesregierung der ganze westen steht
putin und seinem brutalen überfall auf
die ukraine bisher machtlos möchte ich
nicht sagen es gibt ja sanktionen die
wirken auch extrem aber kann ihm bisher
noch nicht so die stirn bieten dass sich
putin geschlagen geben muss jan du bist
heute hier weil wir auch über corona
sprechen müssen da war ja noch was da
gibt es natürlich auch noch und in elf
tagen da ist ja unser freedom day
nämlich am 20 märz was erwartet uns da
gibt es neuigkeiten ja es ist ein
wirklich sagen typisch deutscher freedom
days ist ein gewisser kompromiss wir
kennen freedom day den freiheitstag aus
anderen ländern großbritannien auch
dänemark und da war der freiheitstag
verbunden mit einem wirklichen wegfall
aller maßnahmen in dänemark gab es ja
auch dann monate da wurde corinnas eine
ganz normale krankheit angesehen nicht
mehr als eine ganz besondere so das wird
bei uns nicht ganz der vater in deutsche
ab dem 20 märz das ist dann sonntag in
einer woche wird es nach jetzigen stand
weil das bundeskabinett das heute
beschlossen hat so sein dass fast alle
maßnahmen zwar fallen masken pflicht
beispielsweise in bussen und bahnen wird
aber bleiben es wird auch eine
testpflicht der jetzigen stand weiter an
den schulen geben aber die meisten
maßnahmen fallen und jetzt kommt auf die
bundesländer an auf die
ministerpräsidenten in den bundesländern
denn die haben die möglichkeit noch
zusätzliche maßnahmen je nachdem wie das
infektionsgeschehen ist zu beschließen
also da kann dann beispielsweise auch
wieder können abstandsregeln wieder neu
oder aufgesetzt werden in im
öffentlichen raum das ist dann möglich
wenn man so genannte hotspots also
ausbruchsgeschehen wieder hat also
bundesregierung sagt ich fasse einmal
zusammen mehr oder weniger es gibt einen
freiheitstag leid kann man es vielleicht
nennen einen deutschen freiheitstag mit
kompromissen aber es kommt am ende auf
den ministerpräsidenten und die
ministerpräsidentin im bundesland an
nämlich ob wirklich dann maßnahmen fast
alle fein oder ob es noch maßnahmen gibt
die aufrechterhalten werden